plus deux sans trois mille habitants et
un députés pour les représenter la 12e
circonscription des yvelines s'étend de
poissy à plaisir avec le canton de
montfort l'amaury elle devra choisir si
elle souhaite à nouveau faire confiance
au député sortant david douillet élu en
2009 en législative partielle puis en
2012 avec près de 55 % des voix
le républicain remet son siège en jeu la
circonscription traditionnellement à
droite le donnent favori
l'ancien judoka a obtenu le soutien
d'une partie des élus locaux mais treize
candidats rêvent de lui voler la vedette
parmi eux la marcheuse florence granger
elle est investie par le parti du
président de la république
emmanuel macron son manque d'expérience
en politique pourrait jouer en sa
défaveur
mais elle souhaite incarner le renouveau
le parti socialiste arrivé au second
tour en 2012 avait obtenu 45 % des voix
cette fois il espère rafler la mise
avec sa candidate marie noëlle bas le
front national troisième au premier tour
de 2012 avec près de 10% se fixe
l'objectif de la première place jean-luc
galets représente le parti d'extrême
droite
il était déjà candidat aux élections
départementales de 2015
il avait obtenu 11 85% des voix au
deuxième tour pour faire entendre la
voix des travailleurs au sein de lutte
ouvrière jean pierre mercier délégué
syndical du groupe psa peugeot citroën
il était porte-parole de nathalie
arthaud durant la présidentielle dans
une circonscription à cheval entre ville
et campagne
europe ecologie les verts a investi
patricia charton engagés dans des
associations écologiques locales
elle souhaite préserver la ruralité le
parti était arrivé quatrième au premier
tour en 2012
parmi les autres candidats écologistes
isabelle fournière et florent grassi
antoine barreau candidats france
insoumise devra faire face à la
communiste françoise pinson à droite on
retrouve mario mouillon fabien mettay
pour debout la france et daniel weber
soutenu par jean marie le pen
enfin stéphane roussillo est investi par
l'upm le parti de françois asselineau